wake up before this and this and this
and this that sound people in Britain
and Island woke up like this that's
right
being an alarm clock used to be a job
and they were called NACA uppers we're
traveling back in time for this one so
let's get historian in here just sit
here huh yeah fantastic oh sorry I'm
late the knock her up and didn't call
her good one Richard my name is Richard
Jones and I'm an author on the history
of London okay let's see if we got this
right from the early 1800s to the 1960s
waking people up was a paid job yes and
this was done with a bamboo pole oh yes
yes most certainly this is the age where
people start to work in factories
they've got to be up early for their
shift and of course most people are on
minimum wages they've got a long talks
in the house consequently there's no one
to wake them up so that's where the
knocker up or the knocker up that came
in see in big industrial cities like
London Birmingham and Manchester knocker
uppers used poles to reach the windows
and these poles had a hook or knob at
the end which made them pretty effective
you could since edged a panel in a bit
like nails going on blackboard
wakey-wakey other knock uppers mostly
women used pea shooters to aim at the
windows
[Music]
ha or not but why not just shout wake up
wake up well you do have to keep the
neighbors in mind so the big question is
who knocks up the knocker upper the
evidence suggests that the not proper
just didn't go to bed sometimes with no
proper mitre like tune himself to be
able to wake up at 3 a.m.
ah mystery solved play us out Richard we
had to knock her up and or knock her up
had to knock her up and Anaka ups knock
her up didn't knock on knock her up so
i'll knock her up didn't knock us up
because he's not up
[Music]